[Music]
hey wisecrack Jared here to gaze into
the abyss once more with everyone's
favorite arts and crafts show after was
seemingly canceled in 2015 when season
two bombed true detective is back for a
third season and as you might guess
we're watching closely the first season
was one of the most philosophically rich
shows on TV and it's had a big influence
on the crime genre for the last six
years as countless articles have noted
the philosophy of pessimism is at the
core of true detective
and while philosophical themes are
plastered all over media as of late time
is a flat circle true detective is the
only one brave enough to respond we said
major shut up
but the pessimism of true detective
extends just beyond the ramblings of
rust coal it permeates the very fabric
of the show woven into its aesthetic its
many references to other works and even
its missteps so join us on this dismal
journey through eternity as you realize
that you will watch this video over and
over again
and of course spoilers ahead for seasons
one and two but who we kidding this
episode is 95% season 1 first a quick
recap season one follows detectives rust
and coal a man broken by the death of
his daughter with a rather bleak outlook
on life it's all one ghetto man giant
gutter in matter space and Martin Hart a
man trying to do the right thing in all
the wrong ways they tracked down a
brutal killer with a penchant for creepy
iconography and uncover a massive
statewide conspiracy to abduct kids in
season 2 the show relocates to an
industrial desert town in California and
introduces a few too many new characters
including Vince Vaughn as the living
embodiment of every gangster cliche like
season 1 these three cops and
independent businessman are set on the
trail of a killer who murdered a corrupt
city manager causing all sorts of chaos
around the state what both seasons
achieve though definitely not equally is
creating an atmosphere of pessimism in
philosophical terms I'm what's called a
pessimist pessimism has many different
flavors but philosopher Eugene Thacker
describes it as being marked by an
unwillingness to move be
and the worst the ontological fallacy of
expecting a light at the end of the
tunnel well that's what the preacher
sells damn as a shrink
see this is a school of thought that
believes not that the glass is half
empty but that the glass is broken the
drink has ruined your carpet and the
shards have cut your hands whereas an
optimist by postulate that we live in
the best of all possible worlds the
pessimist would agree but respond that
this is the essence of the problem since
this is the best the universe has to
offer the feeling of dread and doom in
each episode is as palpable as the
memory of eating month-old dominoes but
how does it manage this let's look at
three of the best methods true detective
uses to make one of the most pessimistic
shows on television method one style one
of the things true detective masterfully
accomplishes is creating an atmosphere
of pessimism now part of that is the
visuals and we'll get there but much of
the show's pessimistic aesthetic was
inspired by literature before he made
sure detective crater and writer Nick
Pitts lotto was a novelist and as such
drew heavily from other novelists like
Frank McCarthy Lee Faulkner Thomas
Lagasse and more the Cormac McCarthy's
novels like the road and child of God
explored the degradation of the
landscape alongside the characters
morality and reveal the worst
inclinations of human beings something
explored in true detective this place is
like somebody's memory of a town and
memories fading it's like there's never
anything here but jungle
McCarthy's narrators and characters
often speak in dark monologues and make
crass aside similar to Cole's how the
dick swinger you know you can't buy
crazy put the show also seems to draw
inspiration from William Faulkner
sanctuary sometimes called the original
southern gothic novel southern gothic is
a genre that's typically set in southern
states with grotesque characters gallows
humor and transgressive behavior with
elements of horror and the unexplained
sanctuary is set in these same rural
parts of Louisiana as season one of
truth
and is a story of rape attempted
kidnapping and the wrong man being
lynched and burned but one of Pitts
salado's biggest influences was horror
writer Thomas laqad he's nonfiction work
the conspiracy against the human race so
much so that Pizza lotto was accused of
plagiarizing him whether it's Faulkner
telling us about the realities of
southern justice you're not being tried
by common sense you're being tried by a
jury
McCarthy's pitch-black imagery each leaf
that brushed his face deep in his
sadness and dread
they rode over his face like veils their
veins like slender bones were the Sun
shone brooding or Lagasse's violent
references to the cosmos I wanted to do
things to Richard that would make the
Sun grow cold with horror rushed pick up
fight with the sky didn't language shade
of blue these books featured the same
grim poetry that paints humanity as
little more than a cesspool but Pizza
lattos biggest literary influences on
sure detective are arguably James Lee
Burke for season one and James Ellroy
for season two despite both being called
James and writing hard-boiled detective
nor fiction their stories differ greatly
which is also reflected in the
differences between the seasons of the
show the show often uses the same dismal
poetics to describe the characters or
the setting so your propensity for
obesity poverty a yen for fairy tales in
a similar way to Burke Louisiana is not
a state it's an outdoor mental asylum a
lot of time is spent in both the show
and Burke's writing on establishing the
landscapes to mirror the tone of the
works adding to the sense of smallness
and futility the characters feel in the
face of what they confront both seasons
reflect the pessimistic decay of the
individual with the rotting civilization
around them best exemplified in the
opening credits sequences the books make
heavy use of internal imagery and
metaphor to remind characters of the
horrors they face but on TV this is
represented literally be it in Cole's
visions or the recurring shape of
Casper's burnt-out eyes taking its cue
from the works of Burke and Elroy the
show is able to reconstitute their
approach to create a visual atmosphere
and a set of aesthetic principles that
cop
the dark pessimistic themes method to
intertextuality or as I like to call it
dank references a lot of people poured
over the show's references to classics
of the cosmic horror genre philosophy
and physics it shouts out love crafting
ideas like the psycho sphere hit a bad
taste Mouse Mel a psycho sphere and
specific Elder Gods but it's Robert
Chambers short story collection from
1895 - king in yellow that gets the most
screen time the king in yellow is a play
featured an each short story that drives
all who read it mad the snippets of the
play available in the book talk about a
character called the stranger being told
to unmask as well as a lost city called
Carcosa both of which are explicitly
referenced in season one take these
references are never explained but
simply put there to give the impression
of something menacing yet intangible
behind the mystery veiled barely
understood allusions to an unknown
terror is the cornerstone of cosmic
horror which is why it's no surprise
that cosmic horror guru HP Lovecraft
also references chambers in his story of
whisper in the darkness this has the
cool effect of chambers Lovecraft and
pencil Auto all being in conversation
about the same deliberately intangible
cosmic lore but that's not even the end
of it they are all referencing in 1885
story by Ambrose Bierce called
an inhabitant of Carcosa where a man
finds his own grave amongst the ruins of
a lost city now on top of that pizza
lotto makes veiled references to James
Lee Burke stories by sending rust and
Marty - I'd be rien
he's from Iberia originally after CID he
went home
he's sheriff of Iberia Parish which is
where Burke's Robichaux character is
based then Pizza lotto references his
own novel in the show met my mother on
leave in Galveston we might even view
Cole's investigative method as and
textual this well-read Detective draws
connections between Freud and we'd
encountered a meta psychotic nietzsche
and someone once told me time is a flat
circle and physicist Edward Witten aver
some call to M brain theory to help
solve the mystery and what do you get
when you put all these obscure
references together well as it turns out
not a lot and that's kind of the point
when true detective air the internet was
abuzz with figuring out its many cryptic
references trying to solve the mystery
of the killer while also looking for a
grander meaning to the show and when
many of those threads includes amounted
to nothing people were pissed but we can
better understand this by looking at
something called weird fiction weird
fiction is a genre that defines authors
like Lovecraft beers and chambers
according to authors Joseph Packer and
Ethan Stoneman in a feeling of wrongness
weird fiction is uniquely qualified to
convey a pessimist philosophy one that
invites people to come for the scares
stay for the lingering sense of life's
wrongness weird fiction focuses on the
weird and the horrors of the unexplained
it has a tendency to end abruptly with
no clear ending and stands in contrast
to the optimistic view that things
happen for a purpose that life has
meaning and that humans can come to
understand that meaning
true detective uses these references for
a similar purpose
much like Lovecraft's old ones reduce
human life to insignificance through
their terrifying and unintelligible
grandeur sure detective reduces the
significance of its own narrative by
alluding to a mythos that is much larger
than anything that happens on screen the
references send readers on a futile
quest to decode the yellow King and the
letters of T Leo's delorca uh knocked
over a very old volume the letters of T
Leo's delorca only to be frustrated by a
dead end
and while you may have been mad what
better can we ask from a show inspired
by a guy who would later write pessimism
is guilty of that most inexcusable of
occidental 5
the crime of not pretending it's all for
reason by making it a story about the
vast unknowable horrors of the universe
that references other stories about the
vast unknowable horrors of the universe
it creates its own vast unknowable
universe and aside from the
intertextuality the show is littered
with loose ends as noted by packer and
Stoneman why did Marty's daughter make
this disturbing doll scene what became
of the grandeur tunnel conspiracy to
abduct children and just like in real
life we desperately search for clues as
to a definitive meaning behind it only
for it to totally reject any meaning at
all the third method the show uses to
generate its bleak atmosphere is the
most obvious its themes while plenty
have talked about Cole's pessimism we
noticed fewer people talked about a
specific pessimist theme antinatalism
antinatalism is the belief that we
should abstain from reproducing and that
being born isn't all it's cracked up to
be
now sure that sounds horrible but you'd
be surprised how common an idea it is I
really believe that anyways even
thinking about having a child in this
world is : considering the magical
things it's also how you might feel
every time you watch an Elsa and
spider-man video
Ross Cole is clearly a fan of this
philosophy - I think the honorable thing
for our species to do is deny our
programming
stop reproducing it's not just Russ
Monologues as a lot of Marty's miss is
framed by his relationship to his kids
and wife his family is the center of his
world and creates the excuses for his
most self-destructive tendencies
you got a decompressed before you can go
being a family man
meanwhile the marriage lists and
childless rust is something to be feared
past a certain age a man without a
family can be a bad thing
Marty's worst behaviors are usually
triggered by the mistreatment of
children after discovering the kids
locked up at LeDoux's place he
unceremoniously kills him an act that
needs to be later covered up being
illegal and all he also beats the [ __ ]
out of two prisoners because they slept
with his daughter also super illegal
even Cole can't help but get a little
extra judicial from the mistreatment of
kids somewhere in there I emptied a a
nine and two crankhead for injecting his
infant daughter with crystal and when a
woman poisons her kids this happens you
need to have it yourself
and for Marty being constantly
confronted with the suffering children
endure is what makes him retire Tweaker
tried to dry the kid in a microwave
theorist David Bennett our author of the
cheerily titled better never to have
been believed that coming into existence
harms everyone as he said parents play
Russian roulette with a fully loaded gun
and of course not at their own heads but
if those of their offspring there's also
a bit of fellow antenatal ously Edelman
in their food too convinced extensively
who argued that the cultural obsession
with the figure of the child was
responsible for many of the world's
atrocities
Edelman as a result entertain the idea
that humanity should consider cutting
out the baby making and cruise
interesting
what opit salado's biggest influences is
philosopher Eugene Thakur and his book
in the dust of this planet
Thakur described a kind of cosmic
pessimism that informs much of cols
philosophy for Thakur the kind of cosmic
horror seen in the works of HP Lovecraft
creates a cosmological view understood
not simply as the view from interstellar
space but as the view of the world
without us this idea of a world without
us informs much of Cole's rambling the
affer mentioned intertextuality as well
as the show's aesthetic of the sad
decrepit vistas of Louisiana but you
might be saying the show is not really
pessimistic Cole discovers the afterlife
he even says this and while many fans
felt let down by this about-face packer
and Stoneman have a different read they
argue that society in general is deeply
hostile to pessimism but that works like
weird fiction and true detective serve
as a Trojan horse for the revelation
that everything is actually terrible for
Packer and stone and we should consider
the work of Leo Strauss who suggested
philosophers like Plato and my
quantities added hidden layers to their
work to avoid getting socrates for
telling the truth
Strauss thought that several clues could
help us discover these two-sided works
including blatant contradiction it's all
one ghetto man
giant gutter in outer space Sara's only
dark stress believe that one way these
authors hid their true beliefs was
through some disreputable characters my
off days a star drinking and then so the
authors could plausibly deny their
unpopular beliefs when confronted by
sensors which is why as Strauss says the
greatest literature of the past has so
many interesting Devils madmen beggars
Sophists drunkards Epicureans and
buffoons and while the government isn't
knocking down anyone's door for quoting
Schopenhauer there is a general cultural
taboo for saying like this weird
creatures that should not exist by
natural law that sounds God can awful
Russian in fact the entire relationship
between Russ and Marty puts the normal
reaction to pessimism front and center I
wouldn't go around spouting that [ __ ] I
was you people around here don't think
that way this is perhaps why season two
was such a letdown as it had no cohesive
central thesis no mouthpiece and did its
best to tie up all the loose ends in the
finality this created the weird
sensation of the second season having
the same feel of the first but with none
of the philosophical underpinnings so
what season one's ending just a way for
pizza lotto to make the pessimist
medicine go down smoother well it's
impossible to say but makes for an
interesting reading regardless combine
all these elements of pessimism
antinatalism intertextuality and
aesthetics and you get a groundbreaking
show that gets constantly requested by
people like you as always thanks for
watching guys and hope you enjoy season
3 peace but before you go this video is
sponsored by better help yes that better
help if you haven't heard of them
they're an online counseling service
that operates worldwide to pair people
with licensed counselors that they can
communicate with on their phone computer
tablet etc now you may remember that we
spoke about better held before some of
us here at wisecrack tried it and liked
it so we felt good about promoting the
service but in the last few months
there's been a lot of discussion about
the company online including a series of
videos that questioned some of their
business practices and policies and the
last thing that I want
do is send someone who needs help to
some kind of a charlatan so like a lot
of youtubers out there we decided to
stop promoting them on our videos until
we could see what was behind some of the
claims out there after talking with the
company and following some of the
changes they've made I still think
they're a great option to consider for
people dealing with their own mental
health issues and I'm going to talk
about those concerns and be upfront
about what is great and what is less
great about better health first one not
real therapists so we were really
concerned by a particular allegation
that the company didn't vet their
therapists an idea that arose out of a
disclaimer that was in their Terms and
Conditions now why did they have this
language which put the burden on the
user to verify qualifications I assumed
it was overly protective legalese so I
wasn't that worried about it but after
the concerns came up it made me really
uncomfortable so we spoke to the company
and got more information counselors on
better help must have an academic degree
in their field at least three years of
practicing and at least 2,000 hours of
hands-on experience in short they vet
their therapists and they always have so
to dispel any ambiguity about the manner
the company has since removed this
disclaimer and added in language
clarifying how they vet their counselors
to the money better help can be cheaper
than therapy but for some people the
cost is still prohibitive some people
got surprised by bills because they free
trial expired or the pricing wasn't
clear to them when they signed up after
bringing this up to better help they're
now offering a refund if you are at all
dissatisfied with your experience 3
getting rejected now this one is a
little bit complicated for people
experiencing suicidal tendencies or for
people with specific treatment needs not
really available on the internet better
help is not the right move
getting declined can be heartbreaking
especially if you finally muster up the
courage to seek help however it would be
irresponsible for them to try to treat
people outside their realm of expertise
they admittedly did not handle this as
well as they should have and in our
opinion they need to get better but
they're actively making changes to
ensure that everyone is directed to the
help that they need and I'll tell you
here better help is not a crisis line if
you're in the u.s. and are actively
considering hurting yourself do not go
to better help please call the free
national suicide hotline at
we're gonna put in a description listen
I've used better help and we got
everyone in the office to use it my
experience was as good as any other
therapist I've been to and I've even
personally recommended it to a close
friend of my family
we at wisecrack really believe in the
value of speaking to someone on a
regular basis so if online therapy
sounds like a right fit for you consider
going to better help calm / wisecrack to
get paired up with a licensed
professional in under 24 hours and as
always thanks again guys peace